okay so um
going back to what we were talking about
so this pressure like an eye brace on it
you feel that okay so right that is what
is creating
my experience of struggle of contest
okay
if i was not here
and you did that
there's no experience of struggle of
contest do you get it
okay
so when you push on me and i brace for
impact or push back on you that is
what's creating that
i'm creating it okay
um
if you pay attention i'm gonna do switch
rules now okay
and then you feel did you see how you
leaned towards me before it started and
you held your breath and your mind went
into
kind of oh as your gaze dropped
okay
you can see ah the contest already
started you see but usually we're not
sensitive enough for that so we go
here and we get pushed and we're like
i got pushed and i'm losing my
balance and now we push back more okay
so in this drill you have to pay
attention
i'm already paying attention to whether
i was pushing into you or not do you get
it
or or i have to pay attention whether
i'm already entering into a contestation
relationship with you okay so i'm gonna
not do that
you're gonna go
i'm gonna let you touch me
and then you're going to apply pressure
and i'm going to let it move
this is just a
behavioral drill you got that's all
we're doing right now so not this
and not move out of the way all i'm
going to do
is release this thing
and the more that i release that other
preceding uh anxiety
the more that i release it the
[Music]
okay so if i go like this you can see
you're still stuck because i have all
this tension
but if i just release it
off of me and what i'm practicing is
so
what i'm going to have you do is
try to not already pre
contest and then let us enter into a
contest okay
and then you're going to practice the
releasing skill
okay and try to do it without your
weight going to your heels you see how
it's on your heels already okay
better
don't even as you disconnect don't let
it go to your heels because that's not
marshall okay
it's still going to your heels ever so
slightly
whoa do you feel that
but down to your toes mid foot right
good okay let's try that
okay so
okay
um
you can keep it even in the middle it
doesn't really matter okay
um you feel the pressure
i push into you so that's what i don't
want okay
um
it's not it's not a purely physical
thing because tension in my body
is always gonna be associated with
thoughts and emotions fear etc okay
um and so it's just as we were talking
about if you are
tense
he's actually stuck still i'm pretty far
he's still stuck on me you see
but
also desire to get out of the way could
make him stuck on me and even the
concern he hasn't slipped yet all that
will
do it okay so you're looking more for a
feeling of doing it it's a feeling
uh don't don't think don't try to
give it words oh
no
oh
healing
and then just don't go back to your
heels
so one of the things that
non-contestation does for you
is
you don't have to be stronger than that
than your opponent so
he's much stronger than me i can't get
off my heels from the very beginning do
you see uh which would not be marshall
i'm not marshall that way okay
uh so i don't overpower him and now i'm
on my head i'm on my midfoot vector do
you see okay let's try it again watch
the thinking and feeling go okay so this
was just to uh kind of kind of feel or
to observe how i get in these content
contestations okay
um
and we were using rotational uh
deviation to get it okay
um
you can of course as she goes in
and she comes back there is a desired
depth on her part because she entered
the dichotomous mind frame
so she you have a desired depth to it
and you get it she's in an antagonistic
relationship with me
so the same thing i can absorb it over
this way on that on the same line of
attack but it's not the same line of
attack because
i did not contest her desire
and
okay
so here i just
i'm letting her push me
i'm still in contact
but at no time am i pushing back on you
do you guys got that so as she goes
she's this one
and you'll have their relationship
different would be this you feel that
then i go that's not that's not what
we're doing she goes and i unite with
her you'll get it boom
the reason i'm picking this one is this
one
psychologically emotionally in my
experiences
uh you'll be able to
get out of the way and you're trying to
get out of the way you don't realize
you're still dichotomous to them
this one is on the same line and you're
going to see how you're trying to slow
you down okay
and it's very soft when she goes
very soft
there's no boom and then i try to do
this
right when she touches shh
okay let's try that reconciliation here
all right
next
even when i have an angle of deflection
it should not be antagonistic to you to
get it so it's still gonna let you go
can you see that
so i'm not going
here it lets you go
and that will allow me to do other
things
so it's just basically a person that's
walking at you
and dropping the bridge of their nose
slowly under your hammer stress whoops
that was a little too fast okay so
that's what you're doing she's coming in
dropping
not here you'll stop her she's going the
opposite way the strike we wanted to run
into this truck so boom
push it out
you could of course
she's running into yours
but don't stop their forward progress
don't contest it and you'll add the
oppositional energy to your stripe okay
try to
that's going to be her face
that face right there okay
so this shot is
and it's just going right here on the
original
okay
uh so make sure that it's doing its job
um
what we're doing in this drill is still
just working
with gaining the feeling of
non-contestation okay and the upaya is
like i'd rather not have to fight
against you and i'd rather just hit you
in the face okay
right got it or chop you in the trachea
or knock you out over here or break your
teeth or something with but versus like
oh
okay you guys see that difference
okay
but i'm still not deviating
it's all
emotional
and so i was keeping my feet in place
okay feet in place
um
let's now go
to
deviation
i'm going to move
okay
so
we'll work
this one
shhh
[Applause]
okay let's try that one so i'm moving
in a deviation over to four o'clock okay
let's
just like i could strike you before
uh she goes and i do the same thing in
my weapon i'm able
[Music]
because i'm not occupied with those
things
i'm free you understand because i'm not
captured in this struggle does that make
sense okay let's try that to go for it
he said this concept doesn't change
structurally even if there's more of
their my body that they have contact
with so they're coming in
on like a football kind of tackle
right it doesn't change if you resist
and you're going to add to the struggle
okay
so you're going to feel where her
pressure is i know it's going that way
do you understand
and uh
i can feel there's pressure here on her
head keep going and then this shoulder
comes in you see
so same thing
uh if you go with it
this way
nothing changes
[Music]
don't enter into the struggle
don't run away from it
it's a perfect sweet spot
okay let's try it
these are just these are just drills so
you're looking at the concept and we're
interested in the psycho physiological
releasing okay that allows you to do
non-contestation
um
if if the forces increase right the
momentum the inertia all that is
increased
the concepts remain the same but they do
not look exactly like this okay so for
example if she was really running at me
she
caught me
well you violated the rules do you see
you you stayed yourself still she's
really running at me everything is
uh a little bit opener more open and you
will have a little bit more compression
before you release it you do you
understand
do you understand okay so you can't be
so weak or so structurally
fragile that weight gets shifted to your
heels and things like that okay
there is a
process by which you realize you're
going into a given state or better said
where you realize it's better for you to
go into a yin state okay so if we slow
that faster tackle down
uh when do i go into the instinct when i
realize i cannot keep midfoot vector
here you see that so i let her move me
into
the other state you get it so
there's at that moment there's way more
pressure let's say
that you might experience in your aikido
do you see
um
and that's why like some aikido people
will go that was an aikido they got too
close to but it's because we're dealing
with greater energy values okay it's
still the same thing all right you just
keep that in mind but let's keep this at
this level of just concept and then
trying to gain the skill of releasing
okay so still you you'll have more of my
body okay
uh so we'll do like uh
a clinch okay
she i have a lot of her body you see
that but you you want to feel uh where
i'm at so you're doing the clinch right
okay
so i feel that neck
i feel turn around
i feel this hand
i feel this pressure of her head and i
feel the drive of her legs do you see
okay so i'm going to take away that hand
do you see how i did that so you're
you're there right and i'll take away
that and let's say you're tightening it
up into your hand i'll take it away over
here
do you see
and then um now this is not so tight
because you're not you're only holding
me here with this hand you see that
right and i'll just start
dismantling okay
if she's really driving everything is
neutral but she's driving me forward
he's driving forward you see
well that's going to be the
contestation you're going to try to
deconstruct so she dries you're not
going to go like this okay she's going
to drive and that's what you use
right because she's holding me in place
and she's trying to hold me in place and
then you just start to spend time
so we did a few already going forward
let's do whatever she's holding me in
place so we'll show it from this side
okay
she
she wants that tyson you just move it if
i can't move it here i can move it at
this angle you see and then it's it's
already out
and then you switch the head through
elbow and then
you but it becomes very very soft
[Music]
okay let's try that
all right uh
so
what we're doing in this well you can
say of course she's running at me you
you're just repeating this strategy okay
so here she's got
she was scribbling really hard on
that would be contesting you see then
find out where it doesn't work so i'm
going to follow the in space you see
that was this it's ready to go you can
probably grab it again you see but i
just you're not going to get it and i
come around the head now don't try to
lift this arm up because she's trying to
anchor it down right so you go around
and you push the head down push the head
down
pushing pushing the arm up would be
contestation do you see
it's not doing anything especially once
i get that head down you see not doing
anything
now let's say that she was really strong
or way taller than me and you can't get
the can't get the head down well the
strategy would be not to really muscle
but to go around to something else where
you can do something else you see that's
the non-contest station
of course anywhere in there right you
can go back to some of the drills that
we did boom i got my strike oh
you could have gone to your strikes
because you're not a contestant
right and anywhere in there right you
could keep your throws because any of
those things
aren't as available as any strikes
and you're going
and same thing you can start to draw
your weapons in the middle of what
appear to be a struggle but
is not capturing me okay
um
so don't force that elbow up
and don't force the head down
keep going with the concept okay so one
way
to not force the head down
is you just drive your el your whole arm
down this way
can you see
with my body
my body is doing that you get a superior
leverage to it as opposed to
shove it down here
move around boom you're over here
okay
just work the concept but pay attention
to when your body mind
got you
captured in the contest okay all right